[Music]
nikkei you are I know you to be a very
romantic man thank you
that one times Day Valentine's Day fast
you better talk to such a nice
connection you and your lovely wife
Megan Mullally obviously have a very
romantic relationship Valentine's Day
coming up any plans we're going to be in
Austin playing a couple shows in Austin
together and so we'll go to one of our
favorite restaurants in Austin and then
you know that is our favorite thing to
do and make each other laugh and then
find some remotely private place to have
sex in public you've talked about this
before that's something you really like
is you like to have sex in public
yeah in open spaces I like it's it's
yeah we try and choose a place where we
can get it started without anybody
watching it's like it's like peeing you
know if anybody's looking you freeze up
yeah but you get things going and then
hopefully some pedestrians happen upon
it's thrilling now do you like it when a
crowd gathers is that what you're really
looking for as you won't grow a crowd
what are we talking here
it's 30 to 40 so you're fine with that
okay well I might go to Austin I check
this out
I might just wanna wander by what's
happening 12th and Congress sorry Scott
yeah you know your fans are very devoted
you have very devoted fans and they love
they love them some Ron Swanson they
they love your character that you
portray and parchment creation I'm very
thankful for the why did you sit in such
a menacing way as it was a heartfelt
those hurt felt is what though okay I
thought you were going to kill them I'm
very grateful for that don't don't just
my friend you your fans are so devoted
to you they now are starting to put up
they're becoming obsessed with cats that
look like Ron Swanson are you familiar
with this I have seen some of that yeah
I'm very very flattered there you should
be I pissed some cats look a lot like
you good looking kiss we you're a
good-looking guy let's take a look
there's firstly I love that
take a look at another one right here
[Laughter]
yeah pretty good then let's look at the
last it was moved now I don't know I
can't even tell which one is you
what were you doing in that scene really
cool I don't know I think that was
comedy take number 27 yeah there are
only 28 yeah
so the lego movie I my son is obsessed
with seeing the lego movie he has been
talking about this like it's Halley's
Comet coming back to earth all he
doesn't say to me lego movie lego movie
when do we get to see the lego movie and
then I find out that you're in the lego
movie I role as a pirate as a pirate
yeah a pirate who lost his body to the
bad guy in a previous battle and so he's
cobbled together a new body out of like
a treasure chest and one arm as a shark
right
your your character's name is metal
beard metal beard yeah metal beard and
was it hard doing a pirate was this a
challenge to do a pirate for this well
you know like any red-blooded American
youth I grew up with doing pirate voices
but the the Pirates of the Caribbean
movies have been so popular I didn't
want to land anywhere near any of those
pirates so I just shut my eyes and tried
to imagine what a lego pirate would
sound like
and then I filtered that anything I
wanted to say I sort of put it through a
Popeye filter and I made it kind of
unintelligible yes
and then I put some marbles in my mouth
here we are and you got a paycheck all
right let's take a look at this clip
this is metal beard in the lego movie
let's take a look I thought you said we
were a lost cause yeah did you not hear
me whole story circumscribing the folly
of this whole enterprise that's cut hard
not to hear when you're yelling
everything so why did you come back
this bit doubled land couch I watched
Lord businesses forces completely
overlook it which means we need more
ideas like it thank you ideas so dumb
and bad that no one would ever think
they could possibly be useful oh thank
you
[Music]
[Applause]